[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi est 5
avril l'europe au coeur de l'actualité
avec la visite aujourd'hui d'une
délégation roumaine à la maison jean
meunier située à bazoches la ministre
aux affaires européennes du pays étaient
notamment présentes pour l'occasion une
eau avec moins de calcaire au robinet un
souhait pour beaucoup de ménages est
désormais une réalité pour plus de
quatre cent mille habitants de l'ouest
parisien une nouvelle usine de
traitement de l'eau a été inauguré à
louveciennes les détails à suivre dans
ce journal
enfin retour dans cette édition sur le
premier festival féminin pluriel qui
s'est tenu tout le mois de mars dans de
nombreux le dans de nombreuses salles
yvelinoise un festival pour mettre en
avant la création artistique féminine
nous on ouvre ce journal sur plusieurs
arrestations dans la sphère du meurtre
d'un couple de policiers à magnanville
en juin dernier successivement lundi et
mardi
trois personnes ont été interpellées et
placées en garde à vue dans le cadre de
cet assassinat perpétré au nom de dèche
et parmi ces arrestations celle d'une
jeune femme âgée de 23 ans arrache
également impliqué dans une tentative
d'attentât à la voiture piégée à paris
c'était en septembre dernier
selon les enquêteurs plusieurs liens
entre ces deux affaires ont pu être
établis sans transition je vous le
disais en titre la ministre roumaine des
affaires européennes étaient ce matin en
déplacement dans les yvelines
elle s'est rendue à la maison jean
monnet un des pères fondateurs de
l'union européenne durant sa visite la
ministre a rappelé que le projet
européen avait su ramener la paix sur le
vieux continent
retour sur cette venue avec anne laure
l'anguille 10h ce matin annabi rechal
ministre roumaine des affaires
européennes pénètre dans l'ancienne
demeure de jean monnet cet homme
politique né en 1888 est l'auteur du
texte fondateur de la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier
ancêtre de l'union européenne
jean-monnet the well known
jean monnet est très connu un boom and
its là bas on le considère non seulement
comme un des pères fondateurs de
l'europe et mais aussi comme un
visionnaire c'est donc pour moi un grand
honneur que de venir ici on ne peut que
ressentir de l'humilité dans ce but une
partie de notre histoire
jean monnet a suivi un parcours atypique
il a démarré comme représentant dans le
négoce de cognac avant de s'engager en
politique il fut l'un des premiers
militants de la création européenne
la perspective de jean monnet était
justement une perspective effectivement
fédéral
on peut appeler ça états unis états unis
d'europe états unis d'amérique c'était
son grand modèle qui était le sien la
visite de la ministre en ce lieu phare
de l'histoire européenne n'a rien
d'anodin la roumanie fête cette année
les dix ans de son entrée dans l'union
là oui oui c'est d'ailleurs une façon de
voir positivement l'europe aujourd'hui
consiste à se rappeler ses valeurs et
principes fondamentaux énoncés ici même
hymne aux traces et continuer de croire
en la viabilité du projet européen
au final deux heures de visite et des
changes au cours desquelles des projets
de coopération ont été esquissées la
ministre a notamment proposé que soient
organisées des visites de la maison jean
monnet pour des classes de jeunes
roumains une eau plus tôt ce robinet et
avec beaucoup moins de calquer a71
souhaite exprime beaucoup de personnes
c'est désormais une réalité pour plus de
400 mille consommateurs du département
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine le
site de louveciennes vient d'inaugurer
une nouvelle usine de traitement d'eau
potable celle ci permet d'avoir une ou
avec deux fois moins de calcaire les
précisions avec ces images divines
première
décarbonatation le mot est compliqué
mais le résultat lui est éloquent cette
nouvelle usine située à louveciennes
permet depuis le mois de février
d'adoucir considérablement l'eau traitée
résultat 50 % de calcaire en moins au
robinet du consommateur
il s'agit d'extraire le calcaire qui est
naturellement présent dans l'eau pour en
faire une eau adoucie bonne à bonn à la
consommation elle l'était déjà mais elle
sera encore meilleure donc en fait on
retire le calcaire de la moitié de l'eau
produite
on la mélange avec l'autre moitié est
donc on se retrouve avec un taux de
calcaire qui est inférieur de 50% à ce
qui était aujourd'hui ce qui correspond
aux besoins de la consommation humaine
sans hausse de prix près de 450 mille
personnes profitent de cette eau adoucie
sur le département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine sur l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
huit communes sont concernées guyancourt
et villepreux notamment et si le
calcaire n'a pas d'impact sur la santé
il permet de réaliser jusqu'à 150 euros
d'économie par foyer tous les ans c'est
une usine extrêmement sophistiqué et qui
va permettre à la population de réduire
ses dépenses en particulier
d'adoucissement et surtout d'éviter la
casse d'un math de matériel de tuyaux de
pompe de vannes de machines à laver à
l'intérieur de nos maisons
bonne nouvelle aussi pour l'agriculture
les 30000 tonnes de calcaire extrait de
l'eau sont épandues sur les sols les
plus assidus territoire en période de
vacances scolaires un rendez vous
maintenant pour les plus jeunes à
plaisir les enfants peuvent accomplir
leur rêve et devenir des indiens le
temps d'une animation c'est au centre
commercial grand plaisir une animation
organisée de 11 heures 30 à 19 heures
jusqu'au 8 avril
au programme maquillage réalisation de
sa coiffe entraînement au tir à l'arc et
après tous ces efforts un instant de
réconfort avec la lecture d'une histoire
écouter l'une des responsables de
l'animation le but en fait c'est que les
enfants découvrent comment vie
et comment vivent les indiens les
amérindiens donc il ya différents
ateliers
un premier atelier en fait au cours
duquel ils sont maquillés déguisés de
mon dernier assez pour faire découvrir
aux enfants une autre culture
et nous avons aussi la chance de relayer
cette opération avec l'unicef qui nous
est fourni des panneaux indicatifs qui
explique en fait la situation de
l'enfant dans le monde
nous vous en parlions il ya quelques
semaines des élèves d' hec de
jouy-en-josas ont participé au concours
tous en selle
leur projet monter une comédie musicale
pour des enfants en situation de
handicap
la cérémonie de remise des prix avait
lieu il ya quelques jours à paris à
camille lambert a suivi l'équipe lors de
cette soirée
reportage invité les étudiants à donner
leur regard sur le handicap c'est
l'objectif du concours tous en scène 400
étudiants mobilisés sans vidéo réalisée
et une comédie musicale celle de
l'association backstage d'acheter les
élèves de jouy en josas sont venus à la
cérémonie de remise des prix
ils représentent leurs projets en faveur
d'enfants atteints du cancer
l'idée c'est de réussir à créer une
journée thématique pour leur redonner
leur donner le goût de l'art de
l'expérience de la scène mais aussi à
travers un cadre très intimiste la
visite des coulisses avec nous et de la
dila
la rencontre avec les différents acteurs
du monde de la comédie musicale sont
assez isolé et il nous raconte beaucoup
aussi que même leur vie sociale et c'est
vraiment diminué depuis qu'ils ont eu un
cancer est donc cet événement cette
opportunité en fait c'est le basset on
peut à faire un grand événement avec
plusieurs jeunes qui ont tous à la
terrible maladie prix humour sport ou
coup de coeur il faudra attendre la fin
de la soirée avec les prix mobilisation
établissements pour connaître la réponse
[Musique]
l'association obtient le troisième prix
de sa catégorie et repart avec une
enveloppe de 1000 euros mais la tension
qui monte puis de rechuter et donc c'est
vrai qu'au moment où il annonçait le
privé on s'y attendait pas du tout et
c'était vraiment un plaisir pour nous ça
représente
beaucoup parce que ça veut dire que le
campus est aussi un peu sensible à notre
projet et qui nous a suivis qui nous a
encouragés du serbe
indiscutablement à ouvrir ces jeunes un
spectacle mais ça peut être aussi à des
études ça peut être à d'autres choses et
on est très contents que hec et ce
troisième prix un montant qui les aidera
à financer leur spectacle du 6 mai à
paris mais pour mener à bien ce projet
ils ont encore besoin de 600 euros
un objectif qu'ils espèrent atteindre
grâce à une cagnotte lancé sur internet
une donnée également dans l'actualité à
27 % c'est le taux de femmes metteurs en
scène en france un chiffre qui prouve
une nouvelle fois l'inégalité présente
dans le monde de la culture et pour
lutter contre le réseau créative a rendu
hommage durant plus d'un mois à la
création féminine avec son festival
féminin pluriel en tout 59
représentations se sont tenues jusqu'au
1er avril
alors quel bilan pour cette première
édition la réponse avec ce sujet de
camille lambert d'elancourt aux mureaux
en passant par plaisir et mantes la
jolie
les projets artistiques porté par des
femmes ont fait le tour des yvelines
promouvoir l'égalité hommes-femmes dans
la culture en festival menées depuis fin
février par l'association créative le
bilan est encore provisoire on est déjà
treize mille spectateurs sur l'ensemble
de l'opération
on a eu donc c'est 60 de représentation
on a eu plus de 140 femmes qu'on était
présente sur ce sur cette opération là
et donc ça c'est plutôt oui une réussite
parce qu'on sait qu'on a rencontré
réellement et un public des partenaires
et en même temps une cause
au total quatorze structures ont
accueilli les différentes
représentations pendant quarante et un
jours la clôture a eu lieu le 31 mars
avec la pièce les maîtres du monde
il ya effectivement quelques rares
personnes qui s'intéressent à défendre
les voiles et les projets portés par des
femmes et je pense que si ces gens là
existent c'est parce que ils doivent
eux-mêmes ressentir la nécessité d'un
manque de relais à cet endroit là et moi
j'aimerais pouvoir être programmé
autrement dans ce cadre évidemment en
tant qu'artiste tout simplement au delà
de mon sexe et mon genre aujourd'hui
encore le secteur ne compte que 12 % de
directrice de théâtres nationaux
avec ce festival le réseau créative
espère avoir sensibilisé le public au
delà des yvelines du sport à présent et
les puristes qui ont pu assister à une
compétition d'envergure au palais des
sports d'el en cours il ya quelques
jours le club local de la gm a organisé
elle les demi finales des championnats
de france plus de 300 gymnastes venus de
toute l'ile-de-france de 10 à 30 ans
étaient présents pour ce rendez vous
sportif
retour sur la compétition avec michael
et demi d'euros samedi 1er avril palais
des sports des longs cours le club local
de la gym organise les demi finales du
championnat de france de gymnastique
artistique féminine
une première depuis deux ans chaque
année c'est d'organiser une compétition
et parfois savard eu des fois c'est la
région la zone est une compétition à
domicile à vrai plus pour les 23
gymnastes du club présents pour ce
rendez vous selon la jeune prodige élan
courtoise de 17 ans mathilde de terre ça
change parce que l'on connaît
les agréent on connaît le matériel et
puis il ya
le clap qui est là pour nous encourager
aussi sur le plan sportif les 300
meilleurs gymnastes d'île de france se
sont produits sur quatre agrès le sol à
barres la poutre et le sol
objectif à chaque passage commettre le
moins d'erreurs possibles pour se
qualifier pour les grandes compétitions
de fin de saison
c'est un week-end important surtout
puisque c'est l'objectif c'est de
qualité de ginette au championnat de
france donc c'est un des deux plus gros
week-end de notre saison pendant cette
journée là j'ai mes longs courts moore
pas réussi à remporter six médailles
dont trois en or cinq gymnastes du club
sont déjà assurés d'être qualifiés pour
les championnats de france
un chiffre qui pourrait gonfler dans les
prochains jours pour atteindre 11
participants le classement officiel
définitif sera dévoilé cette semaine un
mot de golf pour refermer ce journal
vous le savez probablement la ryder cup
2018 l'équivalent de la coupe du monde
de la discipline sera organisé sera
organisé du 28 au 30 septembre à saint
quentin en yvelines sur les greens du
golf national
si vous souhaitez assister à cet
événement international les pré
inscriptions en ligne sont désormais
ouvertes vous avez jusqu'à septembre
pour remplir un formulaire sur le site
officiel de la compétition
à noter que les licenciés de la
fédération française de golf seront
prioritaires au total plus de 200 mille
personnes devraient assister à la
compétition donc rendez vous rapidement
sur le site qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay sur notre
site internet tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fils bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]